we all accept the concept of innocent
until proven guilty however what happens
when it's being robbed of your innocence
that makes you guilty
how does and should the system respond
then well it seems lawmakers in Scotland
may perhaps have an answer the nation is
to stop treating children under 12 as
offenders after its Parliament voted
earlier this year to raise the age of
criminal responsibility from 8 when
children commit crimes we have to accept
the system is broken the owners should
be on local law enforcement to figure
out what went wrong and social services
to intervene to find a solution if our
children are going awry it's our fault
not theirs many experts in human rights
bodies including the UN believe that 12
is still too young to criminalize our
kids this may well be true but at least
it's better than eight shortage of
assertions there June and although it's
a very easy case for me to make but I do
have to point to the killers of James
Bulger how was that our fault well I
would say that the adults that were in
those children's law and I'm not in any
way defending what they did sir please
let's make sure we get that clear but I
would say that the adults that were in
those children's lives for sure thing it
was as in yes of course as a society
this was implying funny how no one else
seems to you can run out of your
innocence and the system is broken yeah
then how is the system broken I I think
you have some Halcyon view of perhaps
70s or 80s
we have youngsters now who would slit
your throat as soon as a look at you if
they're caught up in the wrong side of
drug deals or whatever it might be the
idea that we would somehow decide that
it's an opportunity to go easy with them
is exactly the wrong there are very very
very few people are actually prosecuted
in this age well I think in the instance
I'll go there again
it's a horrific case and we don't do I
know but there's someone such as the
killers of James Bulger June on this one
I think you are too respectfully Bolger
shot the nation and it's something that
is imprinted in our memories till this
day
there's gotta be I think a compromise
though in this conversation between
basically providing children with a
criminal conviction and punishing the
wrongdoing and surely we can punish
children in a way that doesn't exclusion
it's not either/or so you could you
could punish somebody like the killers
of James Bulger but not have this
criminal conviction looming over their
heads that then define the rest of their
lives because of James Bulger and I
watched those two trial of his murderers
of course the trolley robert Venables
and now John Barrowman Robert Thompson
and and let me tell you and I'm not
gonna say it now clearly but what they
did to that boy I never know let me
finish my point what they did to that
boy is never published we made a
decision not to publish because it was
so horrific that what they did could not
have been prompted by anything their
parents are done or by anything society
heard Carol do we accept that there is a
difference in terms of how your brain is
forming as a child and how you are an
adult I'll tell you what I would say
that a child from a healthy loving
normal background it's very unlikely to
hire going to commit those kind of pain
we have to ask us cases what's gone
wrong and I do believe we have to look
at the adults in there's that child's
life as much as we are looking at that
child how do you explain for someone
like Kieren Hayward who was Jerris MD
real gentleman his parents did
everything right they were they were yes
what I would say with the tenure I think
you know we can't expect a ten-year-old
to behave to take complete
responsibility for that because we you
can't you won't get married till you're
16 you can't vote or you're 18 or what's
no but but I still think there are
studies that show that eight-year-olds
know the difference between right and
wrong there studies that show that the
brain can be finished by my point is
that that doesn't mean that when we
quotes punish them they have to be
punished as adults but we still have to
do it in a way I think we should clear
some things up I used to represent young
defendants in youth court when I was a
barrister and there are two things I
want to say really this isn't about
letting children off the hook nor
pretending that crimes committed by
young people aren't serious that's not I
think part of the problem with this
issue if you talk to people who work in
the criminal justice system everyone
knows the case of Jamie Bulger is really
the reason why we are an outlier in the
world as having ten of the age of
criminal responsibility and the images
from that trial you know images of those
children leading that little toddler
away have haunted us all Whiteley
because they are so traumatic but it's
not a good thing to do to take extreme
cases there are a handful it's not the
only one and and base policy that
affects thousands of children on the
very most extreme yeah because some I
don't understand why we have to slap a
criminal conviction as a matter of
record
because surely we could this distinction
I was making earlier that it doesn't
have to be either/or surely we could
punish whatever the appropriate
punishment where I agree with June is
that I think as a society this isn't
about saying it's our fault Nick this is
about saying when a child when a child
does something like this when a child
does like this it's our problem that we
should try and solve when that child
goes down that route that is something
we should see as wheat something we need
to fix because that person is still
growing their brain is still has a high
degree of plasticity
starting when we're talking about Crimea
taught by crime growing 4500 knife
crimes okay which is an increase of
seven percent on the year before so so
all the things that people are trying to
do which are not putting them among
criminals and in the system aren't
working because the frequency of the
crimes the severity of your crimes are
none of that I think is directly
pertinent to June's point which is
nobody's saying don't punish them
nobody's denying these crimes happen in
answer to next question if an
eight-year-old murders somebody I'd say
to you that they are not criminally
responsible because they probably have
mental health problems and their brain
probably isn't developed because I
cannot conceive of enabling somebody
with full responsibility and intent
correct and I would save an
eight-year-old murdered somebody or
commits a heinous crime you can not in
any way compare that to an adult doing
the same thing what well for sure they
need to be prosecuted but what I'm
saying is that we also need to look into
what went wrong and we need to look at
rehabilitation because the chances are
even if you do trial them and try them
as an adult they're probably only going
to spend 10 to 15 years in prison and
then they come out as adults who haven't
actually been dealt with young people
dependence on them did terrible thing
right I'm not defending that there need
to be consequences but in every single
case I can recall there was a catalogue
of attempts by people to call for help
to help this most before they got to
that stage whether it was a parent a
social worker a teacher the help was not
available and I would be much more
interested in this conversation if we
tried everything else first if we had
tried to work out how do you help a
vulnerable young person who is showing
the signs of going down that path
who has psychological and emotional
trauma we're not seriously trying to fix
them and just very quickly sorry
reoffending rate of children that have
been convicted they end up forty point
nine percent of children and young
people we offend so we're not actually
dealing with the problem yeah what we're
doing is we're sending them to the
University of crime and then they carry
on committee well there's been some
experiments done some studies done which
showed that some of these kids were
taken some more put into
boarding schools proper boarding schools
I mean I don't mean you know criminals
and others were intensively fostered and
and and it actually that that has had
really great results one it's cheaper to
they're not mixing with crime Walker
wasn't three Jude I'm agreeing with you
yeah but I'm not please let's get that
clear in terms of the Jamie Bulger case
as F was said that is an extreme case
for something that affects thousands of
children none of whom responsibility in
other countries I mean what we're one of
the ten yet Denmark fifteen and we've
got it we've gotta graphically a girl
sixteen Luxembourg eighteen Belgium
eighteen so so in Belgium you can't be
convicted of can I read this UN quote
this is from the UN global study earlier
this year and what it says is childhood
is when children develop their
personality their emotional
relationships with others social and
educational skills and their talents
children should grow up in a family
environment where they experience love
protection and security facing children
in institutions and other facilities
where they are or may be deprived of
liberty difficult to reconcile with
guidance with the guiding principles of
the Convention on the Rights of the
Child and when this bit goes wrong I
believe as a society we should take
responsibility